عندما تضرب الكوارث الأطفال، فإنهم
دائمًا ما يكونون الأكثر تضرراً من
عنف النزاع، فالكوارث الطبيعية
لها آثار طويلة الأمد
يتردد صداها لسنوات وفي كثير من الأحيان
لأجيال قادمة، وهذا هو
الحال بالتأكيد في شرق ليبيا
حيث
نزح حاليًا أكثر من 16000 طفل في
أعقاب تلك الفيضانات الكارثية.
حدث ذلك قبل أسبوعين،
هذا الرقم وفقًا لليونيسف ومن
الصعب أن نتخيله، أليس بإمكانك أن
تتخيل ما يمر به هؤلاء الأطفال
وكيف يتأقلمون
نفسيًا بشكل جيد؟ أجد أنه من
الصعب حقًا أن أتخيل تلك النظرة إلى هذا الشاب
صبي يراقب مدينته المدمرة بينما
تبحث فرق الإنقاذ بين الأنقاض،
فمن المحتمل أن أحبائه
عالقون تحتها أو حتى ماتوا،
وهذا الطفل يقف وسط الحطام الطيني الذي
يصل إلى كاحليه وهو ينظر
إلى ما أصبح عليه منزله الآن
ومن الواضح أنه  في حالة ذهول ومرهق وحزين،
وهناك الآلاف منهم يمرون بنفس
الرعب. ليس عليهم فقط أن
يحسبوا خسارة
منازلهم وحياتهم كما عرفوها من قبل،
ولكن اضطر البعض منهم إلى حمل
آبائهم وأشقائهم وأبناء عمومتهم وأصدقائهم المتوفين.  وبحسب ما
ورد أحصى الناس ما يصل
إلى 25 من أفراد الأسرة الذين يطفوون على
ساحل ما كان ذات يوم واجهة بحرية شاعرية،
في حين أننا لا نزال لا نعرف
عدد الأطفال الذين أصبحوا يتامى، وبالحكم
على عدد القتلى، فمن
المحتمل أن يكونوا بالآلاف
أيضًا.  نجا أحد المراهقين بأعجوبة من
الفيضانات وروى
اللحظات المروعة عندما غمرت
المياه الغزيرة منزله مما أدى إلى
خسارة مفجعة لثمانية من
أفراد عائلته.
لا توجد كلمات يمكن أن تصف الحزن
واليأس في قلبي عندما كنا نتناول
العشاء معًا في ذلك الوقت.  وفجأة
جرفهم الفيضان،
ما زلت لا أصدق أن هذا حدث بالفعل،
وليس كل الجروح بالطبع مرئية
حتى لو تمكن هؤلاء الأطفال من فهم
ما حدث لهم في النهاية،
فمن المحتمل جدًا أن تكون الصدمة
والصدمة  يمكن أن يطمس الواقع
بخيالهم مما يجعلهم ناجحين للغاية
عرضة للقلق والاكتئاب
الخوف الدائم والآثار النفسية الأخرى
المآسي مثل فيضانات ليبيا تخلق
حلقة مفرغة ومختلة للأطفال،
فخ مميت يحرمهم من
أغلى لحظاتهم،
هذا ما يجب أن تكون عليه الطفولة
تلك اللحظات الثمينة أردت إنهاء
هذا من خلال عرض صورة
أذهلتني هنا، يمكنك رؤية بصمات الأيدي الموحلة
التي تبدو
وكأنها بحجم أيدي الأطفال،
ألا تغطي جدارًا في ما أصبح
الآن منزلًا مدمرًا بخفة وسط
الألم  الخسارة وألم القلب هو
المظهر الوحيد للحياة الطبيعية عندما
يكون الأطفال أطفالًا